テイツーや
東海4エアの哲也
あとみね子さん
ご結婚おめでとうございます
本
おめでとうございますそれらの喜ばしい
ことです本当にこんにちははじめ社長です
皆さんすごいですね
先日当該大江あの哲也が昔から教えてやる
もっとアイドルのもとへ君の峯岸みなみ
さんとご結婚されたということで
[音楽]
すごいよいやすごいよもう youtube
ドリューですよほんとに何かネットとか
めっちゃ盛れてましたけどすごいす年
ユーチューバー
を知っと結婚できるのか
まじかや本当にすごいですよなんか
ちょっと前にですけど
徹夜のを打つに遊びに行ったらみーちゃん
がいて
びっくりして心臓止まりそうになった重い
音がありますがすごい本当にめでたいはい
ぱーい
ルール残ってるのかな俺が売れ残ってるん
ですかねそれがモテキで結婚的な皆さん
どうしますこれ町で
周りの人がいよいよ決行してってる気がし
てる当然わかってますあ僕のツイッターに
も書きましたよええ
僕は結構に当てられないともう自分のその
病気タイミングに欠航するのが一番いいと
僕は分かってますもちろんはいもうず如来
やるよもう全然中でいいって思わってると
言い聞かせて何とか目レンタル保って
ふわっちゃ
[音楽]
悦学校できるんだだってみなさんもう
author 昔から youtube 見
てる人ならうわぁそれ懐かしいって言うと
思うんですけど昔樹海に行ったことあるん
ですよユーチューバーみんなで8年前か
もうみんなで遣いって動画撮りに行った時
があったんですよこの時のメンバーがアホ
来始めした長等が今や徹夜しば言うと
トミックじゃん
あと1ちょいなくなっておりますけどなん
かなかった5人無根で見ての
俺が以前きっこシーンですよ
もう
ブーブー人間的神にみんなで何か言った時
のそのみんなてぃ全員結構アティ多いん
ですよコーポ
[音楽]
ブーブー俺と聞こうじゃんっ割とねー
java 犬まあまあでも本当にあの
結構に関してこい
あのまあ
うへぇ
もう無理な顔してネ多いんだー別にそれで
もまあできればいいかなって思ってる感じ
ですねこの鉄塊てっちゃに
おめでとうも電話してみよ
あもしもし
置き換え様ですお疲れさんですで者さんご
結婚おめでとうございます
ありがとうございますどうですか結婚
スターにえっ
[音楽]
ブーブー犬
4メンバーっ俺だぁきゃっですよ
そうです俺だけまだ使いに取り残されて
いるんだ
あそこからへ俺の時ってあそこから昨日
起きましたそうです鉄は予約機能次回から
と見てて増加も分の4が
そうなんですよ web ちょっとなんか
うわマジで俺最後の人になったなぁと思っ
て
あの
って感じです次回面が自分の中での
千匹だったそうなんで結婚さ no
[音楽]
は確かに生活が変わるわけでもない間に何
も変わらないっちゃ変わらないんだけど
うーん
またってねん
好きな人の女神していん
いやーカッコ
いやすごい本当に何か夢があるというか
いいなぁ
ありがたい本当によってた僕はどうしたら
いいですかねぇどうしたらいいかカーン
ねえなんでしょ入って庄山町を選べる立場
というかいやいやそんなことないですね
まぁ正面からぶつかってなんだからズって
いきなり思う人って少ないため順調
一層かなはずで肇社長という人間がシェア
わたってくれたなので興味を持ってくれ
るっていうwii u new まあ私は
わかりやすいザファルやすいからなまずね
誰にはタックしたくなるかっていうかね
なるほどなるほどこれまであった遊ぶまだ
いやーでも使いにあと俺だけなんだよ
しばらく
そんなてもいいですかわかったぞもう
ちょっと次回の言えばどみんとしてるねー
じゃー
自然と二階から
次回のことなる新聞がありますよなるほど
ですねわかりましたありがとういません
じゃさん
語尾に忙しい時にいい
ありがとうございます最後にあの出場した
に向かってないか一言皆さん
安西路があってるー
tetsuya ありがとうございます
すいませんみんな興味ないと思うんです
けども俺の勝手な朝の結婚観というかそう
いうのちょっと話させてくれなんだか
ちょっとショップに僕はよくわかってない
んですよいま結婚したいのが咲くないのか
もちろんしたり人がいたらしたいんですよ
めっちゃだり変なこと言ってるのは自分な
んで聞けるのかよくわからなくなってきた
バッハ家合わせてないでもねぇなんか
いろんな生き方がある時代だからその結婚
すること自体が幸せとも限らないと思い
ますしもちろん結婚せ幸せそうな人もい
ますよただ苦労する人も結構見てきてる
からこの歳になると29年30手前
バジャー
ねえいいかなみたいなそういう葛藤も実は
自分の中に正直今結構したかどうかって
いうのは分からないっていうのが本心なん
かつうと半端にー
その分かります
ダイエット工藤が何だろうそれと全く
わかんないですけどレザーのマニュ人は
みんな結婚するから今の俺のポリシーだけ
喋らせてください僕がポリシー
彼女とかそういうパートナーみたいな人が
できない時は遊びなければ僕がポリシー
ですね覚えただけですけど逆にこの歳まで
来るともう1回遊びまくっていろんな人を
知るほど奥すごい大するか持ってただは
館内に知りすぎたせいで結審月からになっ
ている可能性もあると思うんですけども何
ば
タイミングで絶対であると思うんですよは
この人しかいないなっていう人が俺のゼロ
なんですけどもその人が出るまではもう
遊びまくっていいのかなって僕は思って
ますか減りそうだな
引いてそらもういい自分のしてますよ香美
市弁財変化というのが僕の持論ですね彼女
がいない時はもう遊んでいいと遊びまくる
よ1主次回ぞの雨でパートナーとか好きな
人ができた付き合ったりするとしっかり
その人と付き合いますただと付き合いして
いるときはそれがダメだと思うんだよ
過去の経験上ってかもう当たり前に音を
つけ汁だけそのダメなのでもちろん真剣に
付き合うでも多くをはっきりしする結婚
するためにまで至る過程って大事だと思う
んでぶつかってその結構までの過程は僕
こういう感じだよっていうただ結婚できて
ない人
どうなんでしょうねうわから何が正しいか
分から相手の女性に求めることも最近
ちょっと俺これの話誰と苦闘が一応で
いろいろ話してませんがあんまり男どこで
遊んで来なかったとか一途な子とか真面目
さをな子が好きだ
んですよ好きだったんですけど最近それも
違うなっていう気持ちが中でてきて
だってさあ他の男の人を知らないわけじゃ
俺とかあと23人しか知らないみたいな
女の子ともしお付き合いさせてその人が俺
よりすごい人と化す素敵な人って
めちゃくちゃいるわけじゃないんですか
その人たちを知らないままおりとつけて
いると allようにすごいとと知り合っ
た時に好きじゃなくなれるんじゃないか別
の人に気持ちが移ってしまうんじゃない
かって思っちゃってだから逆に目が真面目
じゃない子っていったら言い方おかしい
ですけどもがある程度をつけ
度が過ぎたらちょっと嫌ですけどいろんな
人を見てきた上でやっぱり私ははじめが
いいわって言ってくれたらもうその人は
気持ち変わらず付きで行ってくれるのかな
とか
名無しさんねーわけわからんはもうそう
いう感じ最近始め実はプライベートでいき
ますまあそもそもなんかさに曽我線出会い
とかないんですけどいいんですそれでただ
隙あれば遊びます素ではタイミングがくる
まで待つばって言うけど正直内心はうわー
なんかホント皆結婚するなって
追っちゃいました
[音楽]
voodooかな
ちょ